[Music]
how do i handle screen time for my kids
all right here's the way we do screen
time in our house
um everybody does this differently this
is how we do it in our house and i will
say this this is based on
walking alongside
countless people
this is based on
um an intensive reading in the
literature
it's in based on conversations with
people in the inside of the tech
industry this is also based on my
individual children okay oh that's the
four ways we make decisions
uh my wife and i so
um how do i handle screens for my kids
number one none of my kids i got one kid
in middle school i got one kid in
elementary school
no phones
no ipads
we do have two decommissioned phones
that just have the internet
for library books on um the digital
books that we get from our public
library
and if you didn't know you could do that
there's several apps you can just go to
public library get books on it's called
books on tape because i was born in the
14th century but you can get audio books
and they're free and you just get them
from your local library it's incredible
it's great and my kids are reading if
you will listening to book after book
after book after book
and it's phenomenal i love it um the
phones are decommissioned the internet's
been removed from them and we are hyper
about um they don't have the codes to
the phones and so to get if they get
locked out they've got to come to us to
get back in
it's annoying for us quite frankly i'd
be out working in the yard i'll be out
working on something and my kids are
working on a project and all of a sudden
they get locked out of the phone and the
the book they're listening to stops they
got to come get us and i got to punch in
the code it's worth it it's worth it um
the next thing is let's see what i wrote
here codes on everything so we got
whatever
you know apps we have to watch things
sometimes it's netflix hulu whatever
happens
we got codes on those things
and
here's how we do screens
maybe they'll watch an episode or two
once a week um during the week
during the school year never i mean
we're like we're pretty pathological
about that because sleep is the most
important thing it's the summertime
right now so we'll say hey we can go
watch a couple episodes um of like you
pick one and you pick one and they go
watch them together
and
they're i mean they're like i don't know
jurassic
cartoon legos i don't know what they're
doing but they're they're cartoons of
some sort um
friday night we have movie and pizza
night and um
so it really is a family thing every
friday we get together and watch a movie
and
usually it's something that or always is
something we can all watch except
occasionally i'll watch you know
my son gets started watching cartoons
and so we'll watch some movie together
and then my wife and my daughter will
watch them together but
um
really the big thing is our house
doesn't revolve around the screens and
we've like i got my kid my son a bow and
arrow we have colors everywhere we've
got instruments everywhere and we've got
places for them to go run and play we've
got dogs we've got chickens
our kids can never say we don't have
anything to do or we're bored and we've
tried to curate a world where their
their imagination can travel with them
wherever they'd like it to go and we're
like
on a safety level my kid my son will
take the dogs and go play in the creek
and i don't i mean it's a waste from our
house
i prefer that on a safety measure than
handing him an ipad and then leaving the
house and him being able to travel down
the
um rabbit hole of the internets with his
12 year old brain
so that's how we do screens in our house
um ultimately it was less about the
restriction on the screens and more
about creating the world i i did i think
i've talked about here
um
it's cost my son some things especially
in middle school that's how kids
communicate they text with one another
and there's a lot of isolation there and
there's been some hard conversations and
he's been right on a few things
my wife and i saved up our money and
bought some
like a foosball table and an air hockey
tech a cheap air hockey table to give
the kids something else to do because i
had said you can't do this you can do
this you can do this he's like what am i
supposed to do man and that was that was
a great critique of of me in my
parenting so
we've had to
shift things the other way if i look at
the cost of an xbox i was able to do the
other things for about that price and so
it was just a matter of shifting
resources one way or another
so that's how we do screens in our house
and everybody does them differently and
i'm not here to judge you um i will
judge you on this way if
a screen has become a digital babysitter
in your house
it's a way for you to offload parenting
responsibility for an hour or two hours
to give a child unfettered access to the
internet
um
it's incredibly unsafe
in so many different ways
and i would challenge you to re-imagine
how your house house works i also know
there's people working for jobs and
they're exhausted and they're scared and
dealing with their own trauma and this
there's a space that i need to have
right now and i get that and i honor
that
make that a short-term solution not a
long-term solution make that a i'm gonna
let this ride for the next six months or
nine months while i am working really
hard to get me and my family from here
to here
so that we can create a world we can
engage one another um
it's not something to carry shame about
it's something to be intentional about
so hopefully that helps